forum de paris sur la ps est ouvert tout
à l'heure une quatrième édition
inaugurée par emmanuel macron et kamala
harris à la vice-présidente américaine
les états unis qui n'avaient pas
participé aux premières éditions sont
souvient donald trump avait pris soin de
boycotter le rendez vous alors cette
fois on se demande si les états unis
vont sceller leur réengagement en
matière de coopération multilatérale une
grande conférence consacrée également à
la réduction à des fractures mondial on
en parle tout de suite avec notre
reporter nadège abderrazak
ladab bonsoir alors depuis la création
du forum pour la paix ans en 2018 c'est
donc la première fois que les états unis
il participe à quels sont les enjeux de
cette présence américaine
absolument la présence de la
vice-présidente américaine signe le
réengagement des états unis dans les
questions multilatérales
après quatre ans de boycott du forum de
paris sur la paix par le président
donald trump alors kamala harris était
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure pour l'inauguration de cette
4ème édition du forum sur la tête un
signe d'apaisement peut-être entre paris
et washington après le scandale et des
sous-marins kamala harris a pris la
parole en premier pour appeler à plus de
parité d'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes
c'est un honneur d'être ici aujourd'hui
de rejoindre les leaders de ce monde et
de discuter d'une importante idée
l'égalité a été en
croire les experts plusieurs experts par
exemple suggère qu'il faudra des
décennies pour que les femmes obtiennent
une parité avec les hommes whitman et
en tant que leader nous sommes
confrontés à ce challenge qui est
immense de taille est effrayant ims and
boys size and sky emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé juste après kamala harris le
chef d'état français a appelé un
multilatéralisme efficace on écoute un
moment même où nous vivions
collectivement une crise inédite du
multilatéralisme
des accords juste signé été remise en
cause
les organisations multilatérales
voyez certains de leurs membres éminents
s'éloigner et donc nous avons
collectivement essayer de bâtir de
nouvelles méthodes chercher de nouveaux
acteurs bâtir un nouveau destin
collectif en étant plus efficaces
ensemble
et grâce à vous toutes et tous nous
avons tenu durant ces années
et je dois dire madame la vice
présidente que de savoir les états unis
d'amérique revenant pleinement dans le
club du multilatéralisme fut pour nous
tous une formidable nouvelle
est donc merci pour cela une trentaine
de chefs d'état et de gouvernement sont
attendus à cette quatrième édition du
forum sur la paix paris qui se tient
jusqu'à samedi ici même à la grande
halle de la villette alors ce forum créé
en 2018 visant à instaurer un rendez
vous diplomatique à paris un peu comme
il se fait à davos en matière économique
ou encore à munich sur les enjeux à
sécuritaire pour cette édition 2021
l'accent devrait être mis sur la
réduction des fractures à l'échelle de
la planète et parmi les autres sujets au
programme est la crise est liée aux
coville 19 bien sûr la cyber sécurité ou
encore l'amélioration de la solidarité
entre les états merci beaucoup à vous un
adage abderrazak pour toutes ces
précisions continue